les forces russes essaye de continuer
leurs manoeuvres au sud via la ville de
miku live qui est effectivement le
dernier verrou avant la grande ville
portuaire d'odessa le premier port
ukrainien alors c'est vrai qu'on le voit
amicaux live est les forces russes pouce
pour entrer dans la ville pour l'instant
les forces ukrainienne etienne le
terrain ils ont repoussé plusieurs
attaques à hier nous nous sommes rendus
en centre ville et aux abords du
centre-ville et les forces russes n'ont
toujours pas réussi à entrer à
l'intérieur de la ville de nicolet pour
l'instant les forces ukrainienne arrive
à les contenir et bien aux limites en
lisière de la ville mais ce que l'on
voit également très clairement amicaux
live est bien c'est que les forces
russes
ciblent de plus en plus les zones
civiles je me suis rendu hier dans
l'hôpital de nicolas yves l'un des
chirurgiens disait qu'au début de
l'offensive
il avait reçu essentiellement des
soldats plus d'une centaine de soldats
depuis deux jours les choses ont
complètement changé maintenant il reçoit
de plus en plus de civils une vingtaine
rien que pour la journée d'avant-hier il
y en a encore eu hier donc on voit que
les russes veulent absolument s'emparer
de cette ville de nicolas yves et elles
ciblent des quartiers civils ou nous
avons été dans des quartiers à
l'intérieur de la ville qui ont été
ciblés par par l'artillerie russe les
habitants savent que cela va durer
longtemps que cela peut durer longtemps
certains sont déterminés à rester mais
quand nous sommes sortis de la ville sur
la route d'odessa qui situe à une
centaine de kilomètres de nicolaï vais
bien nous avons vu des centaines et des
centaines de véhicules en train
d'essayer d'échapper au combat
d'échapper à cette offensive russe et si
les habitants savent également que ça va
durer que les russes vont tout faire
pour s'emparer de me coller c'est parce
que si ils réussissent à s'emparer de ce
verrou ils seront aussi en mesure de
couper la route qui relie odessa à kiev
la capitale odessa gwendoline bon jour
où vous vous trouvez c'est une ville on
l'a dit stratégiques c'est une ville
très symbolique au patrimoine culturel
historique
exceptionnel vous êtes sur place depuis
plus un jour on a le sentiment d'une
ville qui se barricadent peu à peu alors
que les combats ne sont pas encore
arrivés
oui absolument et vous savez on vous dit
en ukraine que des sas est une ville qui
est surtout connu pour son sens de
l'humour enfin c'est comme ça que les
ukrainiens la voie et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui odessa est une ville qui
est très sérieuse c'est une ville qui se
tient prête la plage par exemple où les
les locaux les habitants avaient
l'habitude d'aller et bien la plage
aujourd'hui et pour une bonne partie
minées par avec des mines antichars 1
avec l'objectif est bien d'éviter une
invasion russe par la mer un petit peu
partout en centre ville vous voyez des
sacs de sable des routes sont bloquées
particulièrement aux abords du port et
de la côte l'opéra de dessins qui est un
des symboles de la vie les biens est
entourée de sacs de sable de checkpoint
donc c'est vrai qu'au dessin se tient
prête les les personnes de la défense
territoriale les militaires disent
qu'ils ont le temps qu'ils ont le temps
maintenant de préparer leur défense et
il regarde également du côté de l'ouest
et ont sinistré qui est une région où
les forces russes sont positionnés et où
la ville d'odessa craint également un
assaut